all right we are back with some more
journey best game at night and he'll
only be playing for 50 minutes but it's
pretty amazing so far I had pretty high
hopes of it and it's totally living up
to the hype and that just makes me happy
cannot stop playing this is that the
star we saw in the begin high bank right
for me man
so I got my friend banked with me we've
been home is here for a while
Bank can you push my bag fine fine
see if I care Bank is a random player
online but I feel like we are soul mates
me and Bank I feel like we are meant to
be together nice front Bakula Mita all
right we got another carpet here and
carpets needs songs let me sing to your
carpet gonna find my baby gonna hold a
time gonna grab some afternoon delight
whoa cuz I my mother's always been when
it's Friday
now I'm waiting wha-what is that octopus
doing Bank follow the octopus now
waiting for the moment by the phone my
friend when you know the night is gone
away daddy hey come back here octopus
what is that thing
whoa nice charge brah you're just crazy
man let me fly whoa I jumped on him well
how did you do that banged amazing nice
could've attack her libido means front
flip in Swedish it just sounds funny I
have to explain it for those who don't
know the hell I'm talking about
and if I forget to put look at that
slide oh he shows us the next thing
that's what he was doing Thank You
octopus thank you you are quite the bro
I'll put you on the bro list octopus
okay it's always me doing everything
Bank just goes along for the ride don't
you it's ok bang that's okay holy [ __ ]
that's a lot of octopus are they going
where am i in all that how do you fly
like that banks teach me how to doggie
whoa I'm flying with the octopus
god that's amazing let me fly on you let
me fly on all of you did you see that
thing that was amazing
god damn it it's guys beautiful caps
beautiful you can fly
ah
gorgeous okay what's next
a cinema our bank took me out on a date
all right what do you make out of this
think there's five of them but we're
only two does that mean there's gonna be
more of us banked because I like you and
me together I don't know what I feel
about this banked beg don't fly away
from me are we supposed to fly on the
octopus is that it
all right I'm flying No
now by the hell are we doing let's
follow the octopus
let me fly on you well they go down in
the Sun so I think so epic look at that
what I'm doing that let me bang
look at me bang bang alright
it's not I'll wait for your man sorry I
got a little carried away
it's Shane bang can hear me but I get
the feeling he knows what we're doing I
don't steal my octopus bang that's not
cool
it's very interesting the random co-op I
really wish more games were doing this
it makes it easier if you and along it's
cute
let's camp all right let's see sing to
each other what else you want gonna farm
a babe oh there's something up here I
missed it [ __ ] Bank can you get it I
think there's a secret up there Bank
obviously doesn't know what he's doing
and neither do I helped me octopuses
I got it I got it banked and I'm chillin
in the window
come here bang yes nice going back I
Love You Man just like that movie front
flip I mean cool Aveda where is he now
coming banked we need to follow the
alphabet very activist wearing this game
[ __ ] love it okay why does he buddy
one thing how do they talk anyway
they're freaking octopuses as far as I'm
concerned I actually hate Arthur places
these are like the only acceptable
octopuses all right let's lie down here
bro front flip this is just like
snowboarding only more epic and it's
sand yeah sad boring whoa this is
dangerous
thanks I'm scared hold me
I don't like this Bank
what is this
it's looks evil that
bags say something
I think we're gonna go here bang
bang
there's octopus inside
and we missed something that no
oh they're gonna take us up here I think
Thank You octopus I'll just cover it
here
how we freed them your fray octopus
friends you're free now let's journey
upwards look at that I got them skills
things doesn't even know what's going on
Bank Bank hey you are how I define
what is going on here
well let's investigate evil creatures no
wow
no it's this machinery don't fall down a
bank I need you up here with me Thanks
are you still alive
okay good so why did you eat for
breakfast today Captain Crunch that's
awesome I wish I had some - we should
have breakfast tomorrow
alright thanks sure sure yes this is my
octopus I'm fine you can take it you can
go
come here Jesus there we go
fly on the octopus
fly with bang fly all right what's going
on
where are Oh another eagle I'll take the
one on the left bank
I'll doing oh let's just sit down and
watch the Eagle tell us a story I love
story time with Eagle it's my favorite
what do we got
it's mama mama eagle again
we kind of look like birds we're bird
people with unibrow
all right so our journey continues we
went up the giant architecture machinery
thank you my [ __ ] ish and it's not
illuminating on the bottom floor and the
probably doesn't mean anything actually
nothing but it looks like we're going to
a city next maybe I'm just
misunderstanding this completely yeah I
don't I don't really get it is this
where we are now perhaps honestly like I
it's hard to decipher cipher spraying
because when the mics lips on my lips
you can see by [ __ ] don't even try to
play I tried to rap it doesn't work I'm
sorry
well we're coming closer to the mountain
I don't know if I wanted want to I just
[ __ ] love just chilling with bang
bang dislike my best friend we have the
same taste in cereal what do you think
about this situation bang don't be
scared it's just let's go alright I go
in bank I'll take the one on the left
then our octopus ride it here find the
one on the right once wants me there we
go
wah
beautiful fear
oh man I feel like you bros almost like
if you haven't played it yourself and
you have a Playstation just go download
this and come back to pills I'll be here
don't worry a lot a lot of people have
been suggesting that this is like a game
you need to experience yourself I don't
know maybe you feel it's more fun with
me and Bank I hope so
I mean we're snowboarding the bank is
not gonna be with you like that
ah best flight ever flying way better
than you banked this is amazing look at
this snow our jump gorgeous yes
where's bang if you with me I'm all
scared I'm gonna lose him
all right keep signing the Sun woo are
they are good what's up and see that oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah but when games are so beautiful I
just get like all sentimental be like
this yeah it's games card I don't know
it's probably probably only me maybe has
been custom some effect on it as well I
don't know I can only assume that that's
the case so why do you make out of this
situation bang I'm just following you
right now honestly I don't think this is
the right place to go let me take this
octopus he doesn't like it all right
oh there's carpet here and see it there
we go nail oh it's not a carpet on your
bank yeah we go looks like I'll do all
the dirty work as always you lazy [ __ ]
ping that's okay I still love you I just
think it would be hilarious if the one
who I'm playing when would watch this
afterwards and be like what the [ __ ] I
don't know maybe maybe just me there's
no way to know good job bang don't see
that oh this is my carpet I got it [ __ ]
looks like we unlocked something very
simple gameplay but that's all you need
really you don't need to collect [ __ ]
new coins and you don't need to have
lives all you want is carpets and
octopus and sand and that's it that's
all you need where am i right now
wherever am I in this picture I'm over
here sorry I was just chilling in the
grilling [ __ ] on it being really did
a good job on the camera angles and such
it's kind of cool how would work
it's like my only beef with shadowy
thoughts I know those are very different
games in a lot of ways but let me just
fly up here thanks are you coming Bank
hey you are you crazy [ __ ] always late
good jumping I'm happy for you I'm happy
for you yeah aside it was awesome
what okay
we're jumping we're flying more like it
look I
alright let me fly through this one
point five points 10 points my god
where's Benny hmm oh what's he doing
over there let me go to him
all right we keep going I guess scam so
beautiful I can't take it anyone
oh man ah so inspiring to play this
seriously
my [ __ ] love it keep sliding thank is
always late
it makes me worried when I don't see him
but he always he'll show up somehow I
crazy buffoon let me fly all to because
why not love the color scheme or the
saturation or Q or whatever it's called
alright it looks like we arrived to the
city or that and I got another thanked I
wish I could do this in real life
say say it would have been so [ __ ]
epic
I would just be doing this all day all
day every day painting it up man
just painting it up that's a new verb by
the way painting it up copyrighted you
can't use that I'm sorry
this also makes my my skin look very tan
so the reflection of the screen bonus
points for that game I give this it's
gonna give this 10 out of 10 but just
for that I gave it 10 point wine out of
10 waste paint
where'd is he
I don't want to look for one away for
one second because I feel like I gotta
miss all the Fe
whoa hey
oh my god did you see that banged down
[ __ ] at Bank
Holly [ __ ] Bank we should do this every
day from now I love it I love it begged
all like it's Eagle we get to hear a
story now I love stories tell us a story
Eagle all right let's sit down my friend
and sit down and enjoy this what's up
big ol regions had an epic journey all
right what's happening now are you sad
mama Eagle what's going on talk to me
okay
she's telling me a sad story and I would
assume the carpets go away over here why
and the octopus light is gone and the
carpet connection no don't tell I'm not
going away from mate it's not happening
no way
no [ __ ] way
what is this Thunder that's never good
Oh No what's gonna happen I don't even
know
and I got a think one thing make sure
I'm recording all right yes all right
going down in no we go in here oh [ __ ]
key for the front door